in a devastating bit of news it was
revealed on November 20th 2022 that
Supernatural actor Nikki acox died on
November 16th acox's sister-in-law Susan
Rob saklawsky broke the news in a
Facebook post that the 47 year old actor
and musician had passed away writing my
beautiful smart Fierce incredibly
talented and loving sister-in-law Nikki
acox Rob passed away yesterday with my
brother Matt Rob by her side Nikki and
Matt had a wonderful life together in
California she was definitely a fighter
and everyone who knew her loved her acox
was diagnosed with leukemia in 2021 but
her cause of death has not been revealed
as of this video acox is perhaps best
known for her role as McMasters the
original host of the Meg entity in the
CW's Supernatural you
people for nothing baby I cut a lot more
for a lot less she was a prolific actor
who appeared in a number of high-profile
projects over the years including the
psychological Thriller Perfect Stranger
and the horror film Jeepers Creepers 2.
she also had a role in the second
X-Files movie The X-Files I want to
believe making her one of the few stars
who have appeared in both Supernatural
and the X-Files Nikki acox's talents as
an actor were evident to anyone who saw
her performances on the screens big and
small the people who worked with her
have also been quick to note that she
was quite an exceptional person as well
behind the scenes Supernatural boss Eric
Kripke wrote on Twitter gutted to hear
the great Nikki acox our first Mig
Masters passed away too young she was a
delight and delivered lines like honey
and Venom I Marvel at how she made a
simple word like lackluster legendary
lackluster man
Supernatural regular Jim Beaver also
shared his memories of acocks on Twitter
writing my first Supernatural episode
was with Nikki she was a terrific
actress and a delightful colleague I'm
so sad to hear of her death sleep well
my friend other people associated with
acox's work like the X-Files I want to
believe screenwriter Frank spotnitz and
fellow Mig actor Rachel Miner have also
posted their own condolences
aycox retired from acting in 2014 the
following year she released her first
and only album Red Velvet Room which
contains five original songs created by
acocks herself thanks to her
far-reaching work in the entertainment
World Nikki acox has collaborated with a
laundry list of well-known creatives in
doing so she's amassed a sprawling fan
base that wraps around the world who've
come to appreciate the work she put in
when the cameras were rolling with the
news of her death at the Forefront of
the media fans came out in droves to
honor acox's Legacy in the form of
heartfelt social media posts one fan
tweeted a I loved Nikki acocks and was
so saddened about the news of her death
way too young taken from us I loved her
portrayal of Meg Masters and she brought
her own uniqueness to the character she
will be sorely missed I'm Nick someone
else tweeted Nikki acox I can't believe
this sad news I Loved Her Style her game
she was too young to leave yet another
fan noted how especially devastating
acox's passing is due to its close
proximity to those of fellow pop culture
icons Kevin Conroy and Jason David Frank
this is just the tip of the iceberg when
it comes to online tributes dedicated to
acocks evidently she left a lasting
impact on folks from all walks of life
and her death will not be an easy one
for many to process she will be sorely
missed
foreign
[Music]